Arjabillahimina Shaytana Rajim Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem Alhamdulillahi Khalakil Wujudimina al-Adam Wa Ja'il in Noorimina Zulam Wa Mukhrijis Sabriimina al-Alam Wa Mulkit Taubati Alan Nadam Fa Nashkuru Huaalal Masaibi Ka Nashkuru Huaalan Na'am Wa Nusalli Ala Rasuli Hil Akram Lis Sharafil Asham Wa Nuril Atam Wa Kitabil Makam Wa Kamalin Nabiyina Wa Khatam
Sayyidi waladi adam al-ladi basharabihi aisabnumariyam wada'aliba asatihi ibrahimu alayhissalam hainaka na yarfa'u kawa'idabaytillahil muharram Fasalallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam wa ala adba'i khairil ummam al-ladi barakallahu bihim kaafsatan nass al-arabamin hum wal ajam Wa salallahu ala amir al-muineen al-anza al-bateen waka id al-qur al-mahjalin
Ghalib ala kulla ghalib matluba kulla taalib Alhamdulillah al-Ladhi anzala ala Abdihil kitab walam yaja'allahu aiwaja Alhamdulillah al-Ladhi lam yattakhizwaladan walam yakunlahu sharikun filmulk walam yakunlahu waliyum minaghulli wa kabbirhu tagbira Alhamdulillah al-Ladhi nahmaduhu wa nasta 'ainuhu wa nastaakhfiruhu wa nukinubihi wa natawakkalu alai
Wa na 'udubillahi mensururi anfusina wa minsayyati aamalina man yahdihillahu falamudillah wa man yudillilhu falahadiyallah wa nashadu Allah ilaha illallah wa hdahula sharikalah wa nashadu Anna Muhammadana Abdullahi wa rasuli arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-haq liyuzhirahu aladdini kulli wa kafabillahi shahida wa nashadu Anna Mawlana Ali ibn Abi Talib wasiyuhu wa waziru
Fasallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa salimhum tasliman kafiran kafira Allahum mala ilmalana ilama alamtana inna kaantal alimul Hakeem Allahum ma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'ana bima alamtana Allahum ma inna na'udu bikamina ilmin la yanfa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashpa
Fa ma baadi akullu subhana wa ta'ala fi kitabi hil kareem bada akulla na'udubillahi mina shaytana regime bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yasidli amri Wahlul uqdatam millisani yafpahu kawli Allahum masabit na'indal moutibila ilaha illallah wallahum majal namina ladina amanu amil salihat watawasa bilhaq watawasa bisabr amin ya rabbil alameen Once again assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu
In today's session, we're going to look at the purpose and the need for sending messengers, which are the Rasool, right?
So when I say purpose, I mean purpose from Allah's perspective and need from our perspective.
So the word rasool, it comes from the root word rasala, which means to transmit or to correspond or to delegate forward.
So the idea is that this message or this book, it comes from Allah , but then they're delivered to us through an intermediary or these intermediaries that are called messengers or mursaleen, the plural form.
So then after believing in Allah, His book, His angels, the next thing we have to believe in as Muslim is the messengers.
Now when these messengers, they deliver Allah's message to humanity, there is a response to that message.
It is either met with Iman or it is met with Kufr.
It is met with acceptance or rejection.
Now this word kufr, you'll almost always see translated in books as disbelief.
So a ***** is used for a non-believer or a disbeliever.
And that actually is not the correct translation of kufr and it's not a good translation.
If you look at the root meaning of this word,
Right?
It comes from , which means to conceal, to hide.
The active participle of this root is , which actually means a farmer.
A in Arabic literally means a farmer.
Why?
Because what a farmer does is that he covers a seed with dirt.
He conceals the seed with dirt.
He puts the seed into darkness.
So the idea there is that kufr is placing a covering over something.
That is the essence of it.
So in the Islamic sense, kufr is actually seen as truth concealed.
And the idea there is that in reality, everyone recognizes the truth.
No one can be a disbeliever.
You can either accept the truth, which is Iman, or you can conceal it, which is Kufr.
And this is why the greatest truth concealer in the Islamic worldview is Iblis.
He was actually one of the closest to God, and he knew the truth.
He recognized that Adam was superior to him, but then he concealed it.
using his rationalizations of fire being better than clay now one of the problems with modern Muslims is that they assume that everybody is a ***** if they're not a Muslim right these verses in the Quran
that are talking about the Kuffar are not talking to everybody who's not a Muslim they're talking to people who are arrogant who are puffed up who are filled with pride and who would wouldn't give you the time of the day I mean read the descriptions of the Kuffar in the Quran right there Muta Kabbir there Muhtalun Fakhur there Zalimun
right I mean I mean these are the attributes that Allah gives them in the Quran most people that he talks to in the Quran are simply a nass right a lot of them have simply just not heard the message or not they've not properly understood it or they're just in ghafla you know they're in the state of heedlessness
And Quran refers to these people as anas.
And this is why Allah first calls people ya ayuh hanas before he calls them ya ayuh al kafirun or ya yuladina kafarun.
He simply calls them ya yuh hanas.
If you look at the chronology of the revelation of the Quran, Allah did not initially call the Arabs ya ayuh al kafirun because they weren't kafirun.
But then after seeing miracles after miracles and witnessing everything that they had witnessed and after treating the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam the way they treated him for doing nothing other than calling them to their own success.
That's when Allah said, you know, Haqb al kawl.
No, this is too much.
You're not going to get away with this.
And that's when the verses started turning into Ya'yu hal kafiru.
So that's a very important distinction to make.
Now, what's interesting is that there are many ways to conceal the truth.
And certainly many, many Muslims are truth concealers in reality.
So I can be a Muslim and here I am doing all the right things, fulfilling my obligations, all of that.
But in reality, I'm concealing the truth.
How is that?
The essence of truth concealing is ingratitude.
The essence of truth concealing is ingratitude, not being grateful.
And this is why a ***** is also called an ingrate in the Quran.
Allah says,
You know, He gave you everything that you asked for.
If you try to enumerate the blessings of Allah, you will not be able to count them.
Indeed, a man is extremely unjust and he is an ingrade.
The word kaffar here in this verse does not mean disbeliever.
It means an ingrade.
The idea is that the real reason for sending messengers is good intention.
In other words, Allah has a good intention towards his creation and this is why he sent messengers.
If God simply created the human being and just threw away the manual and said, work it all out for yourselves.
We would all spend our life in turmoil and darkness, and we would have no clue what to do or where to go.
Like that Mullah Naseeruddin.
I mean, I don't know if this new generation, if you've ever heard that name or not, but I know people of my age and we grew up reading these Mullah Naseeruddin stories.
It's a Middle East character that they tell stories using him.
So in one of these stories, Mullah Naseeruddin was in a tavern all night and he goes out early morning, like wee hours of the morning.
He goes out and he's wandering the city just aimlessly, right?
And this policeman comes up to him and says, Mullah, what are you doing out here at this time?
And he says, If I knew the answer to that question, I'd be home in bed.
Right?
But this is the state of many, many people.
They're just literally wandering around in a drunken stupor and they have no clue what they're doing.
And so all they do is they just try to keep themselves just constantly distracted, right?
Constantly entertained.
Rumi talks about the many wines that God has put on this earth to put people out of their misery, you know, these distractions.
He says, Jesus was drunk in the love of God and his donkey was high on barley.
So there are many, many ways that people are trying to deal with this human condition, which is dealing with the pain of existence.
And then they develop this mindset like, you know, John Lennon said, whatever gets you through the night, right?
So there are many people that have this attitude.
I'm just
gonna get through this life, whatever it takes.
That, from a Muslim perspective, is a type of ingratitude because the messengers have come.
They have given people news.
They have given people guidance, but they don't wanna accept it.
It's like if you're thirsty and I give you directions to the river and you say, No, you know,
I'm just gonna watch some Netflix or I'm gonna play a video game and I'm just gonna try to forget that I'm thirsty.
That's ingratitude.
But then there is a whole bunch of people who are trying to distract themselves.
Now, another Mullah story that kind of is another way of looking at this is that Mullah Naseeruddin was looking around one day for something.
And somebody came by and he said, Mullah, what are you looking for?
He says, Some keys that I lost.
So this man starts helping him out, right?
And after about an hour or two, he says, Listen, where exactly do you think you lost them?
So Mullah Naseeruddin, he says, Oh, way over there.
So this man says, Then what are you looking here for?
And he says, The light is better over here.
Right?
There's this idea that people will go where it's easy instead of going where it's hard.
And this is also considered a type of truth concealment to go where it's easy instead of going where it's hard.
And this is where we begin to dilute religion to make our own lives easy.
And this is why these messengers, you know, they are first and foremost, they are human beings.
and this is why they present this incredible example for us through their character by following the book of Allah to the letter setting this this precedent for us that it is humanly possible to achieve what the book says another interesting aspect of prophethood is this idea that we have forgotten our true purpose
We're all distracted by the shine and the glimmer of this world.
And this kind of relates to the Quranic concept of ghazla, which means heedlessness or forgetfulness.
That the human being by his nature is just forgetful.
And if you look at this in terms of the analogy of the Vanity Fair, right?
The servant is sent by the king to go to the marketplace and get something.
but on the way to the marketplace there's this Vanity Fair you know oh I've got plenty of time sun's high I'm going to go look at the fair so he goes into the fair and then suddenly entertainment right suspension of purpose and he gets preoccupied and he just loses himself in the fun and before he knows it the sun's gone down oh my God
The king sent me to the marketplace to get this thing, and the marketplace is closed, and I wasted my time in the Vanity Fair.
So this type of metaphor is related to this human condition, which is ghafla.
That we become immersed in a type of heedlessness because this world by its nature is powerful.
It's powerful in the sense that we get preoccupied.
So how do we remind ourselves?
How do we pull ourselves out of the Vanity Fair and remind ourselves daily that this world is temporal and there's a journey coming?
From the Muslim perspective, it is the reminder itself, a dhikr.
This is why the Quran is called a Dhikr because it keeps reminding us of our true purpose in life.
Now, contrary to our forgetful natures, messengers are awakened beings.
They're awakened beings.
All prophets, they share four common qualities.
The first is truthfulness.
They're always truthful.
They never lie.
The second is trustworthiness.
They're trustworthy.
If he says he's going to be there tomorrow, he's there.
The third is conveyance, that they have this ability to articulate and convey the message.
And the fourth is wakefulness, photana.
Messengers are wakeful beings.
So these messengers, they are individuals who have woken up to the truth.
They are like the cave dwellers of Plato's analogy.
If you've read the Republic in the seventh book where Plato talks about justice, truth, and things like beauty, he gives this allegory of a group of prisoners who have been confined in a cavern since their birth.
And they have no knowledge of the outside world.
They are chained facing a wall and they're not able to turn their heads around.
And there's a fire burning behind them, giving off a light and casting shadows on the wall in front of them.
Now, occasionally people pass by, you know, this fire behind them, getting these figures or animals and some other objects and these objects, they cast a shadow on the wall.
which the prisoner sees as reality.
So they begin naming and classifying these illusions.
And then suddenly one prisoner is freed and he walks out of the cave for the first time.
And the sunlight begins to hurt his eyes and he finds this new environment completely disorienting.
And then when he's told that the things around him are actually real and the shadows in the cave, they were just reflections.
He cannot believe it because these shadows, they appeared so much more clear to them.
But gradually his eyes adjust until he can actually look at the reflections in the water.
He can literally see the objects directly.
And finally he can see the sun, which is the ultimate source of light for everything.
So this freaked prisoner
He returns to the cave to share his incredible discovery with the others.
But since he's no longer used to the darkness, he now has a hard time seeing the shadows on the wall.
And these other prisoners, they think that this journey has made him crazy and he's blind and he has no idea what he's talking about.
And so they violently resist all his attempts to free them.
Very interesting passage.
And Plato introduces this passage as an analogy of what it is like to be a messenger.
What it is like trying to educate people.
The challenges they face when they come to wake people up out of their slumber and their distractions.
They face these enormous resistance, right?
So the cave in his passage is this dunya.
And the world outside the cave is the Akhara.
Everything that we see in this world, every encounter, every emotion, every event, it's a reflection of the Akhara.
But we believe it as being real.
It's just casting a shadow of the Akhara.
But most people are so comfortable in their ignorance that
They actually become hostile to anyone who points it out to them.
But then what's worse is that these people are not even interested in examining the proposition.
And that's what's called acedia.
The word acedia is a Latin term that's generally translated as sloth.
It's actually a Christian theology term, the seven cardinal sins, one of them is sloth.
So they translate acedia as sloth, which means laziness or some resistance to work.
But in the Christian theology, acedia did not originally mean laziness.
You know, people that are lazy in their work.
Acedia, it actually meant spiritual laziness.
That people weren't interested in finding out the truth.
And that's just arrogance.
Allah calls these people Muqmahoon, right?
In Surah Al-Yasin.
And the term Muqmah is a term taken from camels.
The Arabs say, that, you know, when they would take their camel to the water, why would they take their camel to the water?
to help it out, right?
Quench its thirst.
But what the camel would do is it would raise its head up and refuse to go down and drink.
That's a .
The messenger takes them to the river of knowledge to quench their thirst, but they're too arrogant to bow down and take the drink.
And that is arrogance.
And I've met so many of the Quran, why should I read that book?
Well, because one out of every four people actually think it's from God.
That seems like a pretty good reason just to be interested in it, right?
Just to read it and see maybe there is something there.
Give it a chance.
But no, you know, too arrogant to even examine the proposition.
so human beings by default are in the state of ghafla which is the opposite of dhikr or remembrance and this is why in the Quran these two terms are always juxtaposed right heedlessness remembrance heedlessness remembrance they are focused on the outward appearances of things but they are completely heedless about their afterlife
Now, when the prophets come, they tell the people, they give the people a formula.
And that formula is .
There is no god except Allah.
There is no entity, nothing worthy of submission or worship or love except Allah.
And the belief in the Quran is that no messenger has ever come
except that he has said la ilaha illallah.
Indeed the religion with Allah has always been Islam, submission.
So every messenger that has come from the beginning of time has come with this exact same message la ilaha illallah.
That is a universal message for all prophets.
What will change is the second part of the Shahada.
For the Muslims it is now Muhammadur Rasulullah.
At one time it was Isa Rasulullah.
At another time it was Musa Rasulullah.
Jesus is the messenger of Allah.
Moses is the messenger of Allah.
Noah is the messenger of Allah.
So this idea from the Muslim perspective
is that all of humanity has been given these messengers to remind them about God and get them out of their state of heedlessness from, you know, cure their state of acedia.
Now why are they doing that?
To understand that, let's examine this
our religion right our prophet's religion is called Deen al-Islam so let's break this term down the word Islam right it comes from the root word Salama which means to submit to willingly submit to the love of God and we talked about this yesterday that you cannot submit until you love right love is a precondition for submission so Islam means to submit to willingly submit to the love of God
The word Deen in Arabic, it comes from the root Dain.
And Dain in Arabic means a debt.
And so our religion is called Deen Al Islam, which literally translates to the debt of willing submission.
The debt of willing submission.
In other words,
The idea is that we have been endowed with innumerable blessings by our Lord.
And for those blessings, we owe Him a debt of gratitude through our willing submission.
That's Deen Al-Islam.
Allah says in the Quran, Afa ghaira deen Allahi yaboon Do they seek anything other than the Deen of Allah?
Wala hu aslamaman fisamawati wal ardh, tawan wakarhan.
When all creatures in the heavens and the earth, they have bowed down to him in submission.
Tawan wakarhan.
Willingly or unwillingly?
So, what Allah is asking rhetorically is that, do these people seek other than repaying their debt?
When in reality, everything in existence is paying back its debt to its creator by being in a state of submission, willingly or unwillingly.
We see that the sun is in a state of submission.
It will rise and it will set according to what has been decreed for it, right?
It's consistent.
You can calculate sunrises and sunsets for the next 10 years.
Now, what is the power of a human being in comparison to the sun?
We're insignificant, right?
And yet this immense celestial ball of fire, many times the size of this earth is in a state of submission to its creator.
It's fulfilling its purpose.
But the human being is not.
And same goes for everything else in the universe, right?
Galaxies, solar systems, sun, moon, stars, oceans, rivers, mountains.
They're all in a state of submission.
They're doing what they were created to do except the human being.
Now, there are areas of willing or unwilling submission that even we as human beings, we recognize, right?
One of them is the call to nature, right?
We have to do certain things that we cannot avoid.
One of them is to eat.
That is part of our nature.
When we get hungry, we must eat or we die.
We need to drink water when we're thirsty.
If we don't drink, we die.
We have to relieve ourselves once we have eaten or taken drink.
We don't have choice in these matters.
We have to sleep
When sleep comes upon us, there's only so much we can fight it.
Eventually we have to submit to it or we'll go into the state of acute psychosis.
So there is this idea of submission to nature by itself.
And then there is also submission to our own beings, to our physical bodies, our limitations.
We can only eat so much.
We can only drink so much.
We can only do so much physically before we're exhausted, right?
So we have limitations in our movements because just the way our bodies are designed, the structure of our creation.
So there is a type of submission of the self given that we are temporal creatures and we're limited by the physical aspects of our nature.
So in the Quran, there is this idea that everything is in a state of submission, including us.
Everything in the heavens and the earth are in a state of submission, willingly or unwillingly.
But then it is followed by a reminder.
The same verse, it continues.
And to him is their return.
Now, if you look into creation, things are emerging and then they are returning into non-existence.
Everything that has life that comes into existence, it returns back to non-existence.
Plants, vegetables, animal kingdom, ultimately even the mineral kingdom.
All of this is returning back to non-existence after it had come to existence.
So what we've established so far is that everything in existence is paying back their debt of submission to their creator, whether it's willing or unwilling, and they are returning back to the creator.
But the only species that is not paying back this debt is the human being.
And then there's a difference.
The difference is that the human being
is asked for willing submission the human being the insan the believer is asked for willing submission which is which is out of love not by force not same word is used over there there is no compulsion in religion there is no force in religion
So that's one difference compared to every other species that Allah is asking us for our willing submission.
The others, the rest, they are in submission whether they like it or not, whether they want to or not.
We have been given free will.
Another difference is that human beings are not asked about their deaths right now.
Nobody is holding a gun to my head
for repaying this debt that I owe Allah.
When will we be asked about this?
On the day of judgment, right?
Who will ask us about it?
Who's going to take us to account for this debt?
In Surah Al-Fatiha, right?
The fourth verse, , the owner
and the king of the day.
That's Malik.
Malik is the one who's an owner and a king.
So Malik, the owner and the king, Yawmuddin, of the day when the debt of willing submission falls due.
Yawmuddin is the day when the debt of submission falls due.
It's payback time.
How you transact with others is the way you will be transacted with.
It's also called Yaum al-Hisab, the day of accountability.
RasulAllah says in one of the hadith, Haasebu tabla an tuhaasebu.
Take yourself to account before you are taken to account.
Now, here's something really interesting.
There's a debt of submission that we owe Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for everything that He's done for us.
But then there is also a debt that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala owes us.
Isn't that interesting?
So just as we owe Allah a debt, Allah owes us a debt as well.
See when the master issues a command to his slave, right?
The fulfillment of that command is a debt on that slave.
Now there are only two possibilities.
He either obeys the command or he disobeys the command.
If I ask my daughter to bring me a glass of water, she has only two choices.
She will either bring me the glass of water or she will bring me the glass of water.
in both cases right a return falls due on the master if the slave is obeyed and and he fulfills his obligation his master now owes him a reward and if he disobeyed the command then he owes him a punishment and that's essentially yomuddin that's the day when the dead falls due on both on us as well as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and this is why he says in the Quran who will indebt Allah with a beautiful debt why is Allah asking us for this debt for this loan so that Allah multiplies its reward many many times over and returns it back to his slaves
So in this verse, Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala is asking us, His slaves, that who among you will give me a loan?
A loan of good deeds, a loan of submission, a loan of obedience.
Who will indebt me so that I can multiply its reward many, many times over and pay you back?
For he has the most generous rewards, the most noble rewards.
Subhanallah.
So to summarize, this wake-up call is essentially the purpose of sending messengers.
To wake us up, to wake humanity up.
Because we're in a state of heedlessness.
Our day of reckoning is drawing near.
We're losing sand in our hourglass.
every second and we have absolutely no worries about that day.
We are drowned in ghafla.
Let's examine this word ghafla actually because it's quite an interesting word and you know this might get too technical but it's very interesting.
I find these things very interesting because in Arabic linguistics right whenever a word begins with the letter ghain, ghafla begins with the letter ghain
It usually implies some sort of a covering, you know, or something being hidden or something being veiled like , right?
They all have this meaning of being hidden or veiled or confined, like , right?
It's confined.
So the idea is that our intellects have been veiled by the desires and temptations of this world, this .
We're unable to use our intellects, you know, a simpleton or a fool
in Arabic is called mughafal because they're very easy to trick.
You know, like people that fall for these Ponzi schemes, generally they would be called mughafalun.
So that's what ghafla means.
Somebody who, mughafal is somebody whose intellect has been veiled.
The other meaning of the word ghafla is the inability to digest milk, which is also very interesting.
It is the inability
to digest milk, lactose intolerance.
Because milk is one of the most beneficial things in this world for mankind, right?
And so to not accept that benefit, it's ghafla.
And this is nothing against the lactose intolerant, right?
It's just imagery to create concepts.
Because Arabic words have images rather than meanings.
But that's what ghafla is.
And our scholars have said that all of sin, all wrongdoings
are rooted in ghafla that's the basis of it that if you were really aware of God you could never sin you know if God was present in your heart it would be impossible for you to sin Allah says in the Quran
Oh my human being, what has put you in the state of delusion about your generous Lord?
You know this , I need a whole session to explain.
I swear, I'm not even kidding.
I'm not exaggerating this.
, the love in the statement, I need a whole session to explain it.
From a linguistic perspective.
Oh my beloved human being, What has put you in this state of delusion about your generous Lord?
A scholar said, He said, Allah put the answer to that question in the question itself.
What has taken you away from your generous Lord?
What makes you think you can do all these things?
and that you're not going to be taken into account for it.
What did it?
Where's the answer?
Where's the answer in the question?
Your generosity.
Your generosity is what has made me delusional.
I am heedless about sinning because you don't react immediately with punishment.
you're extremely generous with me I mean that's why I sin the people you love the most and and the people who are the most generous with you you take them the most for granted isn't it Allah is so generous in his gifts to creation that we just forget that he's our master and that's what a ghaffla is his
Karam, his generosity, his immense mercy has made us bold.
You know, there's this amazing hadith, I just suddenly remembered, in which our Prophet , he describes this conversation between Allah and his angels regarding human beings.
It's such a
You know, this was one of, I remember, one of the most life-changing things for me.
But according to this narration, the oceans, the earth, and the angels, they are complaining to Allah, right?
And it goes something like, Ma min yawmin illa wal bahru yasta' zinurabbuhu an yogratay ibn 'adam
Wa annal ardha tasta'adhinu rabbaha li tabtali ahum wal malaika tu tasta'adhinu an tu'ajiluhu wa tuhlikuhu That not a single day passes, not a single day goes by that the oceans do not ask permissions from its master.
Ya Allah give me permission to drown them.
They enjoy your countless blessings and then they dare disobey you
Just say the word.
Let me teach them a lesson.
Let me show them your power.
Let me show them your wrath.
The earth begs its master.
Ya Allah, give me permission.
I'll swallow them all.
They walk on your earth, eat from your blessings, live upon it and then not prostrate to you.
Allah give me permission to remove them from the face of this earth the angels ya Allah give us permission it will take us an instant we will annihilate this whole lot of arrogant people in a moment who do these people think they are standing against you
You know, scholars have explained that these oceans, the ocean, the earth, the angels, these entities, these are creations of Allah who absolutely love their creator because they're in complete submission.
And they are shuhada, they are witnesses.
They're constantly witnessing their creator being disobeyed, being constantly rejected, being made fun of.
How would you feel?
How would you feel if your loved ones, people that you love were constantly being humiliated and rejected?
Wouldn't that make you angry?
Right?
So in their anger, in their frustration based on what they're seeing, they call upon Allah for his permission to destroy us.
They are creation just like us, right?
And they want destroy us because of our arrogance.
But our Creator, the one who we are disobeying, the one who we are humiliating, the one who we are ignoring, He says to them, Wa Rabbu ta'ala yaqul, da'a Abdi, fa'ana 'alamu bihi idha an sha'atahum minal 'a'at He says, He replies to them, you know, leave my slaves alone.
I know everything about them since the moment I created them from this earth.
If they are your creation if you created them he's talking to the ocean he's talking to the earth the angels if you created them do whatever you want with them drown them swallow them destroy them do whatever you want if they are your creation
but if they are my creation then hand them over to me and walk away I swear by my power and my majesty if they come to me in the night I will accept them if they come to me in the day I will accept it
Wa in takaraba minni shibran takarabtu minhu zira'an Wa in takaraba minni zira'an takarabtu minhu ba'an Wa in mashi ilaiya harwaltu ilai If he takes a step towards me, I will move an arm's length towards him If he moves an arm's length towards me, I will move a yard towards him
If he walks towards me, I will run towards him.
If he asks, if he seeks my forgiveness, I will forgive him and when he repents on his sin, I will accept his repentance.
man takar raba ilaya talak taytuhu min ba'id waman aarada ani na daytuhu an karib.
When He approaches me, I rush from afar to welcome Him.
And when He turns away from me, I walk up to Him and I say, Awalak karab kun ghairi?
Do you have a Lord that is better than me?
Man ja abil hassanati falahu ashru amthaliha wa man ja abil sayyyati fala yudza illa mithliha wa aarfu wa akhfar Don't you see that when you come to me with one good deed, I reward you ten times over for that deed, and when you come to me with one sin,
I respond with just what is due to remove it.
And even then so many times I choose to forgive it.
Allahu Akbar.
This is our Lord.
This is our loving merciful creator.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Who told you that our Lord is cruel?
Why do we have this impression in our minds that he's just someone waiting to burn us in hell?
He created us with his own hands according to the Quran.
He honored us by having the angels prostrate to us.
What more do we want?
You think he enjoys burning us in fire?
I mean, seriously.
Those of you who have children, right?
Your children make these ridiculous drawings, these stick figures when they're little.
And you proudly stick it up on your refrigerator.
You show it to the world.
You put it on display.
You didn't even create your children.
You just gave them birth.
Mothers didn't do any work in developing the fetus in their wombs.
Allah did it.
And yet you would never do, never do anything to hurt your child.
And Allah enjoys hurting us.
We are His greatest, His most beloved creation and you think He wants to cause us pain?
Where do you get that information?
I don't understand.
Who made Islam so ugly for you?
Who turned this incredibly loving Creator into a monster for you?
I'm shocked when I talk to some of ...
...
my beloved human being, what has put you in this delusional state about your generous Lord?
You know, I really don't know what more to say about this.
It's just ..................